最近有一個同學
上完我的
免費線上課
跑來私訊我
他說台積電
都2000多塊了
你還在用
五百塊的台積電
當教材
根本是亂教
還在誤導新手
老實說
我沒有反駁他
因為如果
你只是想知道
現在哪一檔會漲
那我這套方法
確實不適合你
因為我在教的
說穿了
就兩句話
只做
該做的那一段
不做
不該做的那一段
這兩句話本質上
是在教你
判斷方法
不是要給你答案
所以我不會
直接報明牌
告訴你
要買哪一檔
因為這些答案
保存期限都很短
要嘛幾天
最多幾個月
時間一過
就沒有效了
所以一直以來
我在教的
都是一套
不管股價多少
行情怎麼樣
都適用的操作方法
但我知道
很多人會覺得
現在台股的狀況
跟以前都不一樣
台股4萬點
AI發展很快
再加上各種戰爭
你會懷疑
碰到這種環境
以前的方法
現在還管用嗎
這個問題
我分三個部分講
聽完之後
你會知道
現在這種行情
沒有什麼不同
第一點是
其實
每個時間點的人
都會覺得
自己碰到的行情
是最特別的
2008年的金融海嘯
很多人覺得
股市完蛋了
2020年
疫情剛開始
大家也嚇得半死
台股一度
跌到九千點
但你現在回頭看
那些都只是過程
把時間拉長來看
你會發現
雖然中間
會有大跌
會有恐慌
但股價整體
還是往上走
只是每一次
在當下
大家都會覺得
這次不一樣
但就算這樣說
你可能
還是會卡在一個點
如果我現在進場
剛好碰到股災
怎麼辦
這就是第二點
我可以直接跟你說
股災
一定會再來
差別只是
現在還是之後
只要你在股市
就一定會遇到
只是早晚的問題
但如果
因為這樣
你就不進場
那你避開的
不只是風險
你也放棄了
後面的機會
九千點
你覺得很可怕
不進場
4萬點了
你還是覺得
很可怕
那就會永遠都在觀望
所以真正的問題
不是你會不會
遇到股災
而是碰到的時候
該怎麼辦
我第一堂課
一定會講
最重要的紀律
就是停損
因為沒有人
可以每次都贏
當你發現
判斷錯了
就要及時停損
控制這次錯誤
帶來的影響
也就是說
就算遇到股災
你還是會賠錢
這點大家都一樣
差別在於
你可以少賠多少
很多散戶
不懂停損
也不敢停損
虧損的時候
不認輸
甚至還加碼
最後就是
30％、50％的虧損
或是直接被套牢
但如果你有停損
你的虧損
通常可以控制在
10%到20％
當你一開始就知道
跌到哪裡就要停
你的決策
就會比別人快
股災對你的影響
也會比較小
所以停損
不能保證你不賠錢
但可以讓你
就算遇到
最糟的情況
還是能存活下來
有資金去迎接
下一波獲利的機會
你要知道
很多大行情
都出現在
大跌之後
2022年升息
台股從1萬8
跌到1萬2
當時很多人
都覺得完蛋了
結果隔年AI起飛
台股又衝上2萬點
如果你不懂得停損
這段行情
就只能看
第三點
也是最重要的
當你可以
在任何行情
都存活下來
接下來才是賺錢
但賺錢
不是靠感覺
也不靠明牌
一定要有方法
這個方法
至少要有
三個條件
第一
要穩定
不能一換行情
就失效
第二
要做得到
不是事後
才在這邊說
你應該在這個點買
而是要在當下
就能判斷
之後可能會怎麼走
第三
這個方法
要能告訴你
什麼時候進
什麼時候出
那什麼方法
符合這三點
答案就是
我開頭說的
只做
該做的那一段
不做
不該做的那一段
也就是說
如果行情向上走
就找機會跟
發現開始轉弱
就退出
你不用猜
它會漲到哪裡
強的時候跟
弱的時候退
這種策略
我們叫做波段
它的好處是
你不用一直盯盤
只要定期看趨勢
而且比起
一直抱著
你更容易避開
跌最兇的那一段
別人被套的時候
你可能
早就出來了
甚至一開始
就判斷出
這裡不能進場
但問題是
要怎麼知道
趨勢接下來如何走
這就是為什麼
我的課程
要教你
技術分析
但我要先講清楚
不是算命
它在做的事情是
根據過去
股市的行為
整理出
什麼情況
比較容易
繼續漲
什麼情況
可能就要
開始跌了
也就是說
技術分析的
這些指標、線圖
代表的是
人的行為
而人的行為
很難改變
所以回到
一開始的問題
台積電從五百塊
到現在的
兩千塊
價格差這麼多
以前那套
還能用嗎
我要跟你說
價格可能會變
但股市的
行為模式
是一樣的
這張是
500多塊的
台積電
我把右邊遮住
假設你
現在在這裡
你覺得股價
比較有機會往上
還是往下
如果用
技術分析來看
我用一個
最簡單的工具
壓力線來示範
你看這幾個
圈起來的點
叫做高點
它代表
有一批人
到了這附近
就會想要賣
形成一股壓力
我們把它連起來
這條線
叫做壓力線
意思是
接近這條線的時候
股價容易
漲不上去
但是你再看這邊
這個位置
它這次
超過這條線了
沒有被壓下來
也就是說
原本會在
這裡賣的人
他們不見了
這股壓力
不見了之後
股價就比較
有可能往上走
像這樣
那你再看
一兩千塊的台積電
也是一樣
有壓力
某一天突破
股價開始往上
所以台積電多少錢
不是重點
因為這個方法
幾塊都能用
但我要再提醒你
技術分析
不是法術
沒有100%的勝率
不會因為你
每畫一條線
股市就會照著走
實際操作的時候
會搭配不同的條件
線圖
指標
勝率才會更高
比如大家常聽到的
支撐線
MACD RSI
成交量
這些我都會教你
因為技術分析
就像天氣預報一樣
很多條件
出現的時候
準確率就會提高
你就更有把握
比如說
你看到今天是陰天
不一定代表什麼
但如果
又悶又起風
又開始飄雨
你就知道
等一下
應該會下大雨
所以
如果你不是
只想要我報明牌
代表你其實
已經比很多人
快一步
大部分的人
還在找答案
但你已經開始
在找方法
如果你想把
這套方法
完整地學起來
我有一堂
限時免費的
線上直播講座
我會一步一步
帶你學會
怎麼判斷
怎麼操作
而且因為是直播
有問題
也可以直接問我
報名連結
我放在下面資訊欄
如果點開
沒有看到報名按鈕
那就是暫時額滿了
我是小王子
如果你喜歡
這個影片
幫我按讚訂閱
開啟小鈴鐺
我們直播課見